Murder; call me old fashioned but I’m not
a fan, mainly for moral reasons but also,
it’s just so messy.
Thankfully, the law agrees with me and detectives
have become ever more efficient at tracking
down exactly who is responsible for a particular
crime.
The various techniques have become incredibly
advanced and now involve some of the most
cutting edge science so it’s much harder
to convict people on good old fashioned reasons
such as:
“He has a shifty face” or “She just
looks like the type”.
No body part is safe from forensics these
days, and it’s not just a dribbling obsessive
compulsive with dandruff that leaves behind
saliva, fingerprints and skin, it’s all
of us.
So what are the various techniques that modern
police put to use?
Today we learn; how to catch a killer.
Although the Chinese used fingerprints in
the 700s to identify certain documents and
sculptures, it wasn’t until the end of the
19th century that forensic science really
took off.
The fingerprint was star of the show for many
years, since Sir William Herschel started
using it in India as a way to stop forged
signatures from the 1860s onward.
In 1911, Thomas Jennings was the first person
to be convicted of murder on the basis of
his fingerprints, with a number of experts
on hand to give evidence.
And fingerprints replaced Alphonse Bertillon’s
identification method called anthropometry,
which was a set of body measurements, found
to be far more reliable as a way to ID people
than using early photographs or just asking
“are you Dave?
No?
Okay, I guess you’re free to go”.
Strange though it seems, ballistic fingerprinting
actually started much earlier than fingerprinting,
where an individual bullet was identified
by its shape, not its fingers, in case some
of you were confused.
In 1835, the British police matched a bullet
in a victim to a bullet making mold in the
killer’s house.
Unfortunately, we quickly moved away from
mama’s home-recipe bullets and mass production
prevented this part of forensics, until Calvin
Goddard invented the comparison microscope
in 1925.
The first real test of bullet identification
was after the 1929 St Valentine’s day massacre
when Goddard proved that it wasn’t carried
out by rogue cops but was in fact Al Capone’s
henchmen.
How romantic.
The next big jump was when British scientist
Alec Jeffreys pioneered DNA profiling in,
appropriately, the year 1984.
Big Brother isn’t just watching you, he’s
also collecting your skin.
Of course, since the dawn of civilization,
the most important part of any crime is the
truth; who’s telling it, who’s hiding
it, and what was Colonel Mustard doing with
it in the Billiard room?
In China, three thousand years ago, suspects
were forced to fill their mouths with dried
rice and, after a short while, spit it out
again.
Anyone who’s rice was still dry was found
guilty of lying, since fear and anxiety were
known to reduce saliva.
The first lie detection device that was based
on actual science, rather than some sort of
magic demon stick, was Lombrosso’s Glove,
which measured blood pressure.
This eventually morphed into the polygraph
we know today, you know the machine that everyday
answers the question for millions of avid
TV viewers, “who was the father?”
It measures respiratory rate, blood pressure
changes, and changes in galvanic skin response,
which is the bioelectric reactivity of the
skin.
Of course, no polygraph is completely reliable
since the responses they look for are not
unique to lying, they can be caused by simply
being nervous.
Understanding the way a killer thinks and
behaves has become a huge part of solving
cases, and providing the plots for a never
ending sea of TV detective shows.
The birth of forensic psychology probably
has its roots in the notorious Jack the Ripper
mystery, when an unknown killer terrified
London with a series of bloody murders.
Lacking anything concrete, they tried to build
an image of who their killer was, theorizing
as to whether his motivations were madness,
sexual, religious or a delightful cocktail
of all three.
But the large proportion of forensic psychology
is not trying to work out what kind of cereal
a mass murderer eats for breakfast, but more
on deciding the mental health of people that
are going to stand trial.
The insanity defense is a legal classic and
goes all the way back to the Code of Hammurabi,
in ancient Mesopotamia.
The Louvre in Paris houses a seven and a half
foot stone slab, inscribed with much of the
law set by Hammurabi, the sixth king of Babylon.
It includes mercy for the insane and also
gave us the famous “eye for an eye”.
It also says that you are liable for the lost
crops if your dam leaks, which, speaking as
one of many responsible dam owners among us,
I think is often overlooked in modern society.
Some forensic methods are a little more unusual,
and no I’m not talking about using a large
woman called Ivanka to talk to the dead and
tell us what Elvis was really up to the day
JFK died.
One thing you don’t hear often is, thank
goodness for nuclear bomb testing.
But using the levels of Carbon 14 in human
tissue to get an accurate age reading, has
helped a number of cold cases, all thanks
to the atmospheric nukes we detonated during
the cold war.
This caused a noticeable global spike in carbon
fourteen, which is a radioactive form of carbon
that does occur naturally but we doubled the
level during these tests.
Since then it’s been declining so you can
map the amount in tissue to approximate dates
of global levels.
Meaning we can detect exactly when someone
died just by their carbon-14 levels.
Sometimes though, you don’t need science,
you just need good old fashioned boredom.
Jim Scharf and Dave Heitzman, two detectives
in Washington state, designed a set of playing
cards to give out to bored prisoners, printed
with pictures of cold case victims.
Their logic was that the cards would get around
and some prisoner with a grudge, or looking
to reduce their sentence, might give up a
killer.
And it worked.
In 2011, the “get-into-jail-free” cards
produced a conviction for the 1979 murder
of Susan Schwartz.
And what about the future?
I’m not talking about a Minority Report
ability to stop murders before they happen,
but what tech do we have in the works right
now?
For lie detecting, it would obviously be a
great help to bypass all that obstructive
skin and facial expression nonsense and get
right into the brain.
A functional MRI scan is thought to have a
97% accuracy level for lie detection since
it shows the increased blood flow to the brain,
required to help you create an untrue story.
Unfortunately, it can’t be used on politicians
as they are often shielded from the rays by
their unwieldy comb-overs.
Rumour has it one particular politician has
developed an impenetrable golden mesh of hair
that enables him to lie with impunity.
And as for DNA, well gentlemen, I have some
bad news for us.
It’s now possible to have a good guess at
a man’s surname, just by looking at his
Y chromosome.
This male chromosome has been passed down
fairly unchanged from generation to generation
so by building a database of old samples with
names we know, the police can look for a similar
Y chromosome to yours and it’s almost a
one in four chance that they can guess your
surname.
So, if you want to hire a hitman, either make
sure he’s adopted or just called Agent forty…something.
So I hope this has been useful if you’re
thinking about rounding up a crime-solving
team and, since I’m an equal-opportunities
YouTuber, if you are planning a murder and
this video has helped you, then you are very
welcome.
But seriously kids don’t try this at home.
Thanks for the view, subscribe for more Thoughty2.